today's draft the most important
matchups for week 11. chris you've got
the trivia question all right here we go
if tuataga viola wins sunday at denver
he would join
ben roethlisberger as the only rookies
in the last 40 years to win their first
four
starts who was the rookie qb who won his
first
four starts prior to big ben way back
in 1979 wow
it might this might be my dad
you know it's funny i just asked i know
that's why when
phil was drafted right because because
today's the
32nd 42nd god anniversary of the miracle
in the meadowlands which contributed to
your dad being drafted because the
giants lost that game like i'll go ahead
and say
phil you would be correct
hey all right thank you i'm glad i i'm
glad i checked twitter during the break
okay and saw the joke was it joe
pasarczyk trying to hand off to larry
zonka is that what it was
right apparently the ball had a meal yet
no that that's what brought in victory
formation i think that
that play brought victory formation to
the nfl and
everyone has used it ever since then it
also brought phil sims to the giants
and i don't think you should even get
the first pick here you know you you've
made comments in the past and power
rankings and things that the giants
weren't that great when phil sims is
wearing those old uniforms so
maybe you should just pass this one by
and just let me go first i think i think
you should shut up
all right i i'm gonna go with uh
thursday night football we've been
talking about it
and i'm fascinated by dk metcalf versus
the arizona cardinals secondary is it
going to be patrick peterson are they
going to double them how are they going
to handle dk metcalf is it going to
matter
this time around will the seahawks come
up with ways to get the ball in his
hands
where you could have seven guys on him
and it
who cares he's going to have the ball
and you're going to have to try to stop
him so
i want to see that match up dk metcalf
versus whatever the cardinals do to try
to stop
yeah that that's a good one that's going
to be intriguing to watch tonight if
it's going to be the same approach
is it going to be something different
knowing that seattle's you know
game planning for the way they were
attacked the first time around but
big part of the football game certainly
and just i mean i think this is going to
be
awesome tonight it's a it's it's a
must-win
you know from the standpoint of wanting
to win your division you're getting into
that type of game here tonight so that's
cool in seattle losing three out of four
they're gonna be desperate and pissed i
i gotta go to our sunday night game
i mean there's just there's so many
things and angles here
i mean i really wanna let's just go
basic and say mahomes versus the raiders
secondary
right it's the only loss the chiefs have
had in the last calendar year
the raiders did some really cool things
on the defensive side of the football we
never saw
the chiefs you know struggle mahomes
threw the ball into some crowds in that
game
things like that only interception of
the year right only interception of the
years you don't see
that happen and the raiders brought out
they took the approach of coverage
coverage coverage we're not gonna blitz
them stop doing that it's a waste of
time you can't ever get to the guy
so they dropped seven and eight all game
long
they stole some things from how new
england has attacked kansas city's
offense from the years
so i'm gonna be interested to see what's
that move
from kansas city we heard mahomes
earlier with peter k or
with liam he talked about that game made
us
think about patience and short passes
and things like that
let's see if they can you know pull that
off on sunday and create a different
result
i'm now reminded of talking to jeff
heath after that game and and
and trying to press him for what they
did he said well we got to play him
again so i'm not going to tell you i'm
not going to give it and mike also the
other thing too
the bus ride around the stadium thing
like
i didn't think gruden would do that to a
guy like andy reid who has a prior
relationship
but i brought it up on the show
yesterday and i had
two people text me that no i'm pretty
sure john gurdon did that to
you know shove it in kansas city's face
that's why he did it it wasn't about a
bus driver or anything like that so
i think andy reid knows that and i think
that's gonna make things chippy too
andy reid clearly isn't happy about it
whatever the excuse for it was
he doesn't like it and and that's the
thing when you get the chiefs locked in
and motivated it's over your only
chance to get the chiefs is to sneak up
on them like the raiders did earlier
this year that's why
here's what's going to happen it's going
to be football night america chiefs
chiefs chiefs chiefs the logos by all of
our names and tarica will take the
raiders and the raiders will win the
damn game
next one for me let's let's finish out
the prime time trifecta i'll go to
monday night
aaron donald and tom brady yeah getting
back together again after super bowl 53
what's been the one
way to get to tom brady not around the
edges because he steps up in the pocket
and throws the ball
it's pressure up the middle they've been
using in tampa bay
aq shipley at center they moved ryan
jensen to guard they're going to
continue that until ali marpet comes
back from his concussion they don't know
when that's going to be
communication is important keeping aaron
donald out of tom brady's face
even more important that's how you
rattle him that's how you get him
looking
down instead of looking down the field
and i i want to see if aaron donald can
do aaron donald things he didn't have
any sacks
this past weekend of russell wilson
leonard floyd got all three of them
what happens tonight uh monday night
what kind of havoc
can aaron donald create and will it be
enough to get inside tom brady's head
and disrupt the passing game yeah
buccaneers i'm with you mike it's going
to be a fun one to watch i mean the
bucks are
it's one of the better offenses in
football you know we talked the rams
being number two defense in football and
and that is gonna be a big part of the
football game you know the buck's gonna
have to run the ball a little in that
game too if you think you're gonna be
like seattle last week and drop back and
throw it you know you're not going to
win
if you think you're going to get in the
shotgun and just be oh we're going to
throw the ball we're the bucks we got
like we saw in the saints game they'll
lose the football game you got to run
the ball at the rams a little they're
very creative and coverages they're well
taught that way and you want to slow
down aaron donald
run the ball at him a little bit that's
the best way to do it all right i'm
going to a big sunday match up i got to
go to that ravens titans game
derek henry versus that ravens front
seven
i mean the ravens front seven that
should be feeling kind of embarrassed
with the way they were pushed around
last week against the new england
patriots
ravens football teams don't get pushed
around like that too often
they don't i mean it's really rare when
you see that of course you know derek
henry and the titans and mike frable saw
it and are going wait we'd like to do
some of those things too
so i that is one where you know here the
ravens are getting into a little bit of
a
whoa we're reeling mode here too they
need to correct the
you know the the trajectory of their
team and the titans are in the same damn
boat
i mean this is a big football game in
the afc and these are two
you know you lose this one and they may
not make it you're not in the playoffs i
mean that's what's amazing
i mean so yes i i want to see how that
shakes out
and can derrick henry run the football
on that ravens defense
i thought it was a little bit bizarre
yesterday we played the sound on pftpm
of ryan tannehill the titans quarterback
explaining that derek henry's touches
have been down
recently by design well the design
hasn't worked because
they've been losing since they've
reduced derek henry's touches but that
feels like something that should be
coming from
mike vrabel the head coach or arthur
smith the offensive coordinator was just
odd to have ryan tannehill being the one
who explains
the strategy behind fewer touches fewer
carries
fewer opportunities for derek henry to
carry the football i think
more is what you need if you want to try
to find a way to get back on track
they've got the colts rematch in indy
coming up next weekend
you know the ravens could be done by
week 12
they have the steelers on thanksgiving
night the the titans could be done
by week 12. uh one of these teams
is is going to be in huge trouble next
weekend especially if they don't win
this week and all right the last one for
me
whoever plays quarterback for the saints
against the falcons defense
i still don't know who it's going to be
how can you not be fascinated by that
matchup what can the saints
do with jameis winston or taysom hill or
some of both
right we know drew brees is going to
miss two weeks with the
rib injury five fractured ribs collapsed
lung he's still got a shoulder problem
too that was on the injury report
yesterday
uh so he's not playing well who is so
far
hey here's what here's what i'm
impressed by i haven't checked this
morning
but the saints practiced yesterday
nobody blabbed yet no
as to who got the reps so sean payton
has managed to put the kovorka on
everyone to keep their damn mouth shut
and uh uh i like it i like it although i
still think at some point it's going to
come out
i would think so too that somebody
somewhere at least
you know oh i think you're going to see
more of jameis or more of taysom hill
you know i think there was somebody from
nfl media who released something that
said we would see
they said expect to see a lot of jameis
which is planning the flag to say
i was right it was going to be jameis no
right come out and say he's the starter
don't say expect to see a lot of jameis
winston say he's the starter yeah if
that's what you're reporting
i know the game yeah no i hear you i'm
expecting that so that
we'll see i'm i am intrigued by that my
last pick i'm going to go
aaron rodgers is that cult's defense
colt's defense number one in football
they don't blitz ever that front four is
very good
you know packers offensive line we know
they're good pass protection offensive
line
can they protect rogers enough to where
he can make his plays and do his things
there
that'll be a bit that's a big game for
both football teams that'll be a fun one
to watch
xavier rhodes knows rogers from his time
in minnesota rogers knows rhodes i
wouldn't be surprised if rogers has a
few
tricks up his sleeve to expose rhodes
the way he used to be when he played for
the vikings
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports